تعمل روسيا على زيادة عدد
القوات وكذلك
استعدادها وقدرتها على
العمل والقيام
بأعمال عدوانية في غضون مهلة قصيرة جدًا ،
لذا فإن عدد القوات
يرتفع
بينما ينخفض وقت التحذير ، هل
عتقد أن هناك فرصة لذ
ك  سوف تغزو روسيا هناك خطر حقيقي
ونحن مستعدون للعديد من
السيناريوهات المختلفة كل شيء من
غزو كامل
إلى عدوان عسكري على نطاق أصغر
ضد أوكرانيا
للتخريب
والهجمات الإلكترونية الكبيرة ، لذا يجب أن نكون
مستعدين
ولكن بينما نستعد لـ  الأسوأ أننا
نعمل بقوة أيضًا من أجل حل سياسي
وسلمي ، ولا يزال من
الممكن لروسيا أن تهدأ من مدى
أهمية هذا الالتزام من
الولايات المتحدة بإرسال هذه
التعزيزات هنا إلى الجناح الشرقي لحلف الناتو ،
وأنا أرحب بشدة
بنشر المزيد من
القوات الأمريكية
جزئيًا بسبب  الولايات المتحدة هي
الحليف الأكبر إلى حد بعيد وهي تساهم
في الآلاف من القوات ولكن أيضًا
لأنها بالطبع  يبعث برسالة قوية للغاية
عن الالتزام الحديدي
للولايات المتحدة تجاه الأمن الأوروبي وحلف شمال الأطلسي